et ce qui est manuel Macron va tenir bon
sur sa réforme
je le pense sincèrement je pense que
c'est très forme
elle a été faite au nom de d'abord de la
nécessité de maintenir la solidarité
intergénérationnelle et de préserver
notre système par une partition qui est
un des meilleurs du monde aujourd'hui et
en second lieu elle est nécessaire parce
que si on veut préserver cette mesure il
faut que demain elle soit à l'équilibre
et donc on dit souvent cette réforme
elle est à la fois
inutile et les ajuste je crois que
elle est normale elle est nécessaire
parce que on pense bien que le fait de
démographique montre que notre système
métabou je vous donne un seul chiffre
qui n'est pas souvent évoqué il y a
aujourd'hui 17 millions de retraités en
France en 2030 il y aura plus de 20
millions de retraités est-ce que vous
pensez qu'avec un tiers des Français en
retraite on peut travailler moins demain
non je ne pense pas ça c'est une raison
démographique le gouvernement ne l'a pas
mis en avant il a parlé de justice
donc on y viendra tout à l'heure avec
Brigitte Etam mais vous je note que vous
ne reprenez pas textuellement les termes
initiaux du gouvernement vous dites
c'est d'abord pour des raisons
démographiques le Emmanuel Macron dites
vous ne va pas caler vous dites je le
pense sincèrement vous en êtes sûr dans
votre for intérieur titre personnel j'en
suis sûr bien entendu je pense que c'est
une forme qu'il a essayé de mener
d'abord de façon systémique pourquoi
parce que en mai 68 sans doute le
gouvernement voulait tenir pourquoi
est-ce que saturer son quinquennat comme
on le dit s'il n'arrivait pas à bout de
cette réforme le problème c'est pas de
savoir si tu as le problème de ces
savoirs et là si on arrive aux mesures
de justice si demain la France peut
avoir dans 10 ans 150 milliards de
dettes supplémentaires 15 milliards par
an et si nos enfants et nos
petits-enfants peuvent avoir une
retraite de peau de chagrin pas assurée
du tout
est-ce que s'il devait céder ça tuait
politiquement sans quinquennat
honnêtement je vous réponds à la
question je ne vois pas aujourd'hui ni
le gouvernement ni le chef de l'État
cédé un engagement qu'il a pu envisager
je pense qu'il ne pense qu'il essaiera
pas parce qu'on ne peut pas c'est
Olivier du soft le ministre qui porte
évidemment cette retraite au
gouvernement soutenait hier dans les
colonnes du Parisien que la réforme est
de gauche est-ce que ça n'est pas une
énième maladresse formulé par un membre
du gouvernement sur cette réforme de
dire que c'est une réforme de gauche
quand vous comptez quand vous avez
besoin de vous appuyer sur les voies de
droite pour la faire passer et bien
justement
quand les républicains au Sénat vous
disent ça sera la réforme des
républicains elle sera de droite et que
le gouvernement dit aujourd'hui non
c'est très forme elle a d'abord été
initié par le gouvernement il y a eu des
discussions qui ont été faites avec les
républicains et il y a dans cette mesure
des mesures qu'il n'y a jamais eu dans
la proposition qu'on fait la républicain
ou Sénat pendant quatre ans il proposait
la retraite à 65 en 64 ans sec sans
mesure à côté or dans cette loi il et on
nous le reproche jamais parfois il y a
pour plus de 6 milliards de mesure
d'accompagnement social qui vise les
carrières longues les carrières hachées
la pénibilité et l'emploi des seniors il
y a 7 milliards donc c'est 7 milliards
ce sont des mesures sociales qui sont
aujourd'hui fait de là pour corriger
pour partie les difficultés de retraite
contre les carrières insuffisantes
proposé de décaler à 64 ans l'âge légal
de la retraite jamais comme on peut on
dire aujourd'hui comme le fait l'olivier
du socle que c'est une réforme de gauche
je vous l'ai dit parler de mesure
sociale qui l'accompagnent et parce
qu'en fait on voit bien que la réforme
Touraine et ses 43 nuités
et la boutique et la boutique en 2030 à
la retraite à 64 ans des facto elle y
aboutit donc c'était bien déjà cette
réforme qui aboutit qu'on le veuille ou
non aujourd'hui la plupart des gens
prennent leur retraite à plus de 63 ans
avec la réforme Touraine et quand on a
commencé avec 43 annuités à 22 ans on
est à 65 ans vous voyez ça vous dites et
de gauche et de droite c'est je dis que
c'est une réforme juste équilibrée
nécessaire
[Musique]